Why do some companies succeed over the long term
while others do not?
If you could only list two things, what would you say?
The truth is most firms don't adapt, they die.
Their assets are repurposed.
Sadly, very few firms, even the most successful firms
last more than a few decades.
If you would compare the list of firms on the Dow Jones
in the late 18th century,
you might be surprised that the only one to survive
at least until the 21st century was General Electric
and now they're no longer part of the Dow Jones index.
What distinguishes successful companies
from unsuccessful ones?
My answer, and it's supported by a lot of research,
is strategy and management.
Companies that succeed have strategies
that are build on deep insights, prescient foresight,
forward thinking, bold innovative experiments,
a sense of cleverness in the management team.
They have strategies that are coherent and well-formulated.
And importantly, they have courageous leaders,
organizations with strong values and powerful cultures.
They have effective and compelling management teams
who lead and whose organizations
are anxious and excited to follow.
When you look across highly successful firms,
four common elements stand out.
First, they all have goals that are simple,
consistent, long-term focused and that are known
and agreed upon among all members of their organizations.
Nothing derails a firm more quickly
than goals that are unrealistic.
Perhaps more importantly,
what distinguishes successful firms from others
is that everyone is on the same page.
Everyone is pulling in the same direction.
I was once engaged by a major entertainment firm
to do some consulting.
There were about 30-35 managers in the room.
I asked them to go to whiteboards
and write down the essence of their company's goals.
Sadly, I think we ended up with more different goals
than the number of people in the room.
Rob Grant, the author of our strategy text,
compares in an earlier edition
the objectives of the North Vietnamese
and the U.S. in Vietnam.
General Giap in the North Vietnamese
had a single unifying focused ultimate goal
of reuniting Vietnam under communist rule
and expelling a foreign army from Vietnamese soil.
And they were prepared to take as long as it took to do it.
In contrast, the U.S. efforts in Vietnam
would be deviled by confused objectives.
Was the U.S. supporting an ally?
Stabilizing Southeast Asia from communist expansion?
Fighting a proxy war with the Soviet Union?
Or fighting an ideological war against world communism?
In retrospect, it is easy to see why the U.S. gave up.
Second, successful organizations have deep
and profound understandings of a competitive environment.
Successful firms have built strategies
that are based on some unique and clever insight
about the industries.
These insights are not always complex and profound.
Let me relate a story.
Who remembers a firm called Blue Ribbon Sports?
A business from the 1960s.
I suspect most of you are drawing a blank,
but some of you will have had said, "Ah yes."
That's Phil Knight's first firm.
The precursor to what we know now as Nike.
What was Phil Knight's profound insight?
How was he able to break into a highly competitive
athletic shoe industry dominated internationally
by adidas and Puma and domestically by Converse and kids.
Some of you are thinking
it was because he was a passionate runner.
This gave him the insight to gain entry
into the athletic shoe market.
But that's not where his profound insight came from.
As the story is told, Phil Knight
had finished his MBA at Stanford
and took a sabbatical in Asia
before returning to his job as an accountant
with one of the big eight firms in those days.
While in Asia, he got to observe
the manufacturing competencies of many different companies.
He also came to appreciate that if you were trying
to make high quality athletic shoes at a competitive price,
you probably didn't wanna manufacture those shoes
in Germany, France or the U.S.,
where adidas, Puma and Converse were made.
As the story continues, he returned from Asia,
quit his job at the accounting firm
and started designing shoes in his kitchen
with a waffle iron,
with his coach from the University of Oregon.
His simple yet profound insight
was that he could produce a better quality athletic shoe
at a more competitive price
if he outsourced production to Japan.
This simple insight was the beginning of the firm
that we now know of as Nike.
Let's continue the story though.
Fast-forward with me from the '60s, if you can,
to the early '80s.
Out of nowhere, small British athletic shoe firm
took over the world.
Reebok had discovered its own simple yet profound insight
that allowed it to carve out a significant position
in the highly competitive global athletic shoe industry.
Do you know what their insight was?
I'd like to make the point this way.
Reebok had had the same epiphany
that my three-year-old son had had one Sunday afternoon.
As parents typically do,
my son was taking a bath with his baby sister.
In the middle of his bath,
he had made a discovery, an epiphany.
He jumped out of the bath,
came running into the living room,
jumping up and down, butt naked, water everywhere
and pronounced, "Guess what, Daddy?
"Boys and girls are different!"
You should smile with astonishment
but Reebok had discovered and exploited a market opportunity
based on the simple idea that boys and girls are different.
Up to this point in time, the athletic shoe industry
had approached producing women's shoes
from this perspective that they needed
to be smaller in size and offered in pastel colors.
In the early '80s,
Reebok introduced a line of women's athletic shoes
that were specifically designed for a women's physiology
and the types of exercise women most commonly engaged in.
It certainly didn't hurt Reebok
that it began to offer women's shoes at the time
when aerobics became a huge global exercise phenomena.
Remember the leg warmers and the leotards?
Reebok was able to leverage the simple yet profound insight
into a global market position.
Let's continue the story one more time.
Out of nowhere, a small Los Angeles firm
caught the imagination of the U.S. in parts of Europe.
A small little startup firm called LA Gear
had identified another simple and profound insight
about the athletic shoe industry.
Some of you will remember the two-color laces,
the flashing lights in the heel.
What had LA Gear discovered?
Their insight was based on observing
how people use their athletic shoes.
They discovered that the majority of people
who purchased and wore athletic shoes
did so without ever intending to use the shoes
in some form of athletic activity.
People were buying the shoes because they were comfortable
and they looked good.
LA Gear's strategy was to design athletic shoes
with an eye to fashion.
In the heyday, in the mid-'90s,
they were selling a half a billion worth of shoes globally.
To me, LA Gear lost its way
when it tried to compete head to head with adidas and Nike
in producing high end athletic shoes
for professional athletes.
Had they stayed focused on athletic shoes with fashion,
I think they'd might be still around today.
By the way, the entrepreneur who started LA Gear
went on to create SKECHERS.
In all successful winning strategies,
you will find a real element of cleverness.
Good strategies always look obvious after the fact.
But when they are formulated,
a good strategy will always have some insight
that is profound in some way or another.
Third, successful strategies are based on an honest
and objective appraisal of resources.
Strengths are identified and magnified
but, and perhaps more importantly,
weaknesses are acknowledged and protected against.
People always want to talk about competencies
but no one wants to talk about incompetence.
No one wants to say, "We're not good at doing that."
When firms are not realistic
about what they can and cannot do, they quickly fail.
Successful firms know what they're good at
and what they are not good at.
Successful firms recognize that they have
to continually upgrade their skills and resources
in order to continue to be successful.
Fourth, successful firms are exceptional at execution.
Without effective implementation,
even the best thought-out strategies
will amount to very little.
Successful firms have galvanizing leadership.
Their top management teams
are capable of reaching tough decisions.
They're exceptional at creating an organization
full of highly motivated team players.
Great firms don't just do one thing 100% better,
they also do 100 things 1% better.
While some want to argue that success is really due to luck,
or that some firms have an easier access to more money,
or better resources at the beginning,
you'll find that these four factors
are almost always present in some form or another
in highly successful enterprises.